different folks would get rid of
the headphone jack
boy that i would love to be a a fly in
the wall of those
discussions we had that oh
that was a that was a discussion that
happened almost every year
yeah that was an every year should we
get rid of headphone jacks on the ipod
yeah right when are wireless headsets
going to happen what it right and it
took years to build all the right
protocols the chips all those things to
make the experience that is the i
airpods today
right
to say have the confidence because
bluetooth was good but it wasn't apple
like so nat it's like we got to make our
own chips we got to make our own
software stacks now we have the
confidence to remove the headphone jack
and actually make you pay 200 more for
your iphone that you were just paying
because it's a headphone jack now we've
grown our revenue we've given a new
experience to the user right and
ta-da you know it's just it's magic and
now if the world's transformed to
everyone you know moving to that right
but it took years to understand the
problem develop the technology to and
not just rush it to market to get a half
experience but to get it right and
refine it then ship it and only then
after
it was probably four or five years in
development just like the m1 processor
right
that was a work
from 2008
right
grinding away grinding away grinding
away then saying okay now we have the
confidence we're doing our own silicon
for all the iphones and ipods
uh ipads and such
now we're going to turn to the mac and
make sure we have the best processor
right not just that we have the best
integrated design team
and then
saying we're going to you know and then
besting everyone making sure the
software's
and the hardware is designed at the same
time making sure the kernels all those
things are are gonna use the best
efficiency
and then popping it out
and then it feels seamless it's magic
there were no
as far as i could tell unless you were
real esoteric drivers or something like
that it just worked it was magic like
the transit it wasn't even a speed bump
it was not even a crack in the road
you